>>> YOU'RE A MAN.
TOUGH.
STRONG.
RUGGED.
YOU NEED UNDERWEAR THAT'S THE
SAME.
>> NOT SOME DESIGNER JUNK THAT
COMES IN FANCY LITTLE TUBE.
>> FOR MY MANLY BODY, THAT AIN'T
GOING TO CUT IT.
>> MIGHT AS WELL THROW THOSE
UNDERWEAR RIGHT IN THE TRASH.
>> IF YOU'RE LIKE ME, YOU'RE
SICK OF THROWING YOUR UNDERWEAR
IN THE TRASH.
>> YOU WEAR THEM ONE TIME AND
MAKE LITTLE MISTAKE, NOW YOU
HAVE TO THROW YOUR UNDERWEAR IN
TRASH AGAIN.
WHAT A RIP OFF.
>> NOT ANYMORE.
>> INTRODUCING JAKE'S NONSTICK
UNDERWEAR FOR MEN.
THE ONLY UNDERWEAR THAT'S MADE
WITH THE SAME HIGH-TECH CERAMIC
COATING USED ON
THE WORLD'S FINEST COOK WARE
ENSURING MAXIMUM PROTECTION FROM
YOUR MANLY MISTAKES.
>> YOU'RE MAN AND YOU WORK HARD
FOR YOUR MONEY.
>> STOP WASTING IT BY PUTTING
YOUR UNDERWEAR IN TWO PLASTIC
BAGS, TIEING IT IN A KNOT
AND THROWING THEM IN BOTTOM OF
THE BATHROOM TRASH EVERY TIME
YOU MAKE MISTAKE.
>> WITH JAKE'S NONSTICK
UNDERWEAR MY MISTAKE SLIDE RIGHT
OFF RIGHT DOWN MY PANTS LEG.
>> THEY ARE EASY TO CLEAN.
WIPE WITH A CLOTH OR DRY PAPER
TOWEL AND THEY ARE AS GOOD AS
NEW.
>> NOW THE ONLY THING YOU GOT TO
WORRY ABOUT IS
PUTTING THE PAPER TOWELS IN TWO
PLASTIC BAGS, ALONG WITH YOUR
PANTS, SOMETIMES WITH YOUR
SOCKS, TIEING THEM IN A KNOT AND
TOSSING THAT OUT OF YOUR OFFICE
WINDOW.
>> THAT'S WAY CHEAPER.
NO MORE ITCHING IN YOUR BOARD
MEETINGS.
>> NO MORE HEARING YOU KNOW WHO
MAKE FUN OF YOUR MISTAKES TO HER
FRIENDS.
>> GIRL, IT WAS LIKE SOMEBODY
DRAGGED THIS MAN IN MUD.
DON'T MAKE NO SENSE.
HE DIDN'T EVEN NOTICE.
>> YOU SHOULDN'T HAVE TO FIND
NEW UNDERWEAR EVERY TIME YOU GET
NERVOUS AT AN IMPORTANT DINNER.
>> OR YOU COUGH TOO HARD.
>> OR YOU GOT HIT IN THE
STOMACH.
>> OR YOUR PROTEIN POWDER
DOESN'T AGREE WITH YOU.
>> OR BECAUSE YOU HAD WHISKY
LAST NIGHT.
>> OR SOMETIMES NOTHING AT ALL.
YOU WIPE REAL GOOD FOR AN HOUR.
NOTHING IS ON THE PAPER AND THEN
YOU GO HOME, IT'S ON THE BACK OF
YOUR PANTS.
>> HE'S LIKE A LITTLE BOY.
>> I'M A MAN.
>> YES, YOU ARE.
ASK YOUR DOCTOR ABOUT JAKE'S
NONSTICK PRESCRIPTION UNDERWEAR
FOR MEN.